a cluster of overgrown mounds on disused
land marks the site of a massacre here
outside the city of Kaunas Lithuania
lied the remains of an estimated five
thousand Jews over 70 years ago they
were rounded up marched to this spot and
killed by their own countrymen says
route Ivana gaya - but such things have
not been talked about in Lithuania
before now Vonnegut is the best-selling
author and she's written a book on
lithuanian complicity in the Holocaust
5000 citizens of Lithuania killed by
another a couple of hundreds of our
citizen is not an important part of
history it's a first first mass murder
site industry in ever so it is worth of
it's just this kind of stick and in the
private territory and the few stop being
organized there it just sets a lot of
bad things about my country and about
the attitude to the people who were
killed on the outskirts of Vilnius a
local resident recalls his grandmother's
account of what she witnessed nearly
2,000 Jews were murdered here my
grandmother told me that they drove the
Jews past that planet over there then
they collected their valuables their
glasses earrings wedding rings and so on
and they led them into the forest and
made them line up there were women
carrying babies among them
then came the machine-gun fire Tata tar
and the old fell into the pit
grandmother told me that the pit was
full of bodies as a bowl with soup and
who drove the Jews there the Lithuanians
who else
there weren't any Germans there may be
one or two standing off to one side
Nazi Germany carries the principal
responsibility for the Holocaust but how
great was the complicity of the
Lithuanians this is the subject of a
bitter debate currently raging in the
country Vonnegut has spent half a year
scouring the archives and the Lithuanian
capital Vilnius she discovered that her
own family had been involved in the mass
murder of Lithuanian Jews I realized
that you know my grandfather who was a
hero who was anti Soviet and suffered
for Lithuania also was not I wouldn't
say the perpetrator or the killer but he
was one of the people who made this
Massacre possible so it means that my my
country's history the victims and heroes
could have been you know participants of
the murders as well in the summer of
1941 German forces occupied Lithuania
but after two years of foreign rule by
the Soviet Union many Lithuanians
welcomed the invaders as liberators this
banner says Lithuania serves the Fuhrer
the Nazis had no trouble finding
collaborators whether it was a thousand
or twenty thousand is hotly disputed but
there can be no doubt that with their
help over 90 percent of Lithuania Jews
about two hundred thousand people died
in the Holocaust
Ruta Vonnegut ah is not afraid to face
her critics not even the right-wing
extremists as they marched through count
us on the Internet vana Gaeta has been
reviled as a traitor you say the
Lithuanians liked killing Jews I doubt
that no I didn't write that well I
haven't read the book nobody's read the
book but everybody thinks I want to harm
Lithuania Varna Gita says she intends
just the opposite she wants Lithuania to
face up to its past a first step could
be to publish a list naming the
Lithuanian collaborators that the
historical institute compiled in the
fall of 2016 after years of controversy
matada member laven remained Efraim
Zuroff recites the mourners Kaddish a
Jewish prayer for the dead his
great-uncle was among those murdered in
Lithuania as director of the Simon
Wiesenthal Center in Jerusalem zurafa is
one of the principal Nazi hunters he's
been supporting Vonnegut his efforts for
years and pressuring the Lithuanian
government to admit to the country's
role in the Holocaust
it's full of places like this this is no
different then dozens and dozens and
dozens more than 200 such places
beautiful forests in the middle of a
beautiful forest all of a sudden you
have a mass murder site the Jews we're
not never considered you know our
citizen people like us that the memory
should be respected they were you know
they deserved what they what they got
that I mean people wouldn't say it
openly but the why the place I neglected
never visited and you see nobody even
give a thought that these people are
there they were not brought to nice
cemeteries they are there in five six
layers root Ivana Gaeta and a frames are
off say the situation is unacceptable
they intend to carry on until Lithuania
is ready to face its past
you